listen congratulations on this album uh
you know you recently post on social
media a big thank you to everyone in
your life who contributed and helped you
make this album come to life you also
thanked your fans and I loved what you
said you wrote thank you for letting me
take the time to grow up make mistakes
and learn from them so you could make
the most authentic and truthful album so
how does it feel that there are so many
songs on this album that are so you
um honestly
uh it's quite normal for me to write
such personal records but
um I've never had records take me like
back to such specific times in such
specific places like I feel like I enter
a time capsule when listening to this
album and I go directly back to where I
was in the place I was riding them and
my state of mind
um so you know this album has been a bit
emotionally
um
tough to get through at certain times
like especially like listening through
over again and stuff there's certain
songs that are a little I'm a little
more sensitive to than others but
um
for me
I'm so happy and proud to finally have a
body of work out there that does
resemble me and who I am so much because
I I think you know just by growing up
and that's kind of something everybody
goes through is like growing up and
finding themselves
um but
it just yeah I I really feel like I I
did that with this record and I and I've
never felt more connected to my music
and Artistry before that is incredible
did you feel like when you were putting
these songs together because I know
you've been working on these songs for
quite a while did it feel like a healing
process
definitely in the moment uh like in the
process of writing them I don't know if
I notice it as much because it was a bit
difficult
um at times and a lot of it was also
like in the moment
um so but for me the creative process of
of focusing on the production on the
album and working with Mike crossy
um executive producer of the album
was so amazing and something I never
been
that physically involved in the music
side of things or where you know being
so Hands-On
instrumentally and with the Dynamics and
with all the different musicians and
arrangements and drums I just I really
fell in love with like actual like the
actual music side of things
um where I felt like I had kind of lost
what I loved so much about music
whenever I kind of lost myself as well
so I really feel like I just I found a
lot of myself in that studio
that's amazing uh you know when you look
at all the songs on the hardest part
when you look at this album all together
what do you want to say with this new
music
you know a lot of this music
I think is about
finding who you are and stepping out
into the world on your own and
um
I think at no matter what point in life
you're at uh
the things that I hopefully the things
that I talk about
um can reach people and people can
relate to them and
um
feel not like the only ones that are
that are um
going through the things that I speak
about on this record so I for that I
hope I hope that by me talking about
some things that are kind of hard for me
to talk about that can kind of lend a
friend to somebody who
is also going through the same thing or
is I I internalize everything and I go I
go I I deal with everything like trapped
inside my body and it's hard for me to
like verb it's hard for me to sometimes
I think or
I'm sure other people too to verbalize
how they're feeling or I with me I kind
of
think about everything in my head before
I talk about it out loud and this music
wasn't it was a was an outlet
from for that and I hope that this music
can be an outlet for others as well you
know a song like unfinished I know that
you wrote that at 16 and then you know
as time went on you kind of went back
and you rewrote that a little bit did
you find that you would go back and
rewrite uh certain songs on this album
when you realize you changed as a person
yeah definitely I I rewrote the song Mr
Percocet probably like three times oh no
I love that song so good thank you I
yeah that that that I I felt like I
wrote it at one time and it was more of
like
um
uh like a login to a journal like I'm
just getting everything I wanted to say
out
um so I felt like lyrically there were
just some tweaks I had to do to like
actually make it like a song rather than
just like a personal entry
um which a lot of my songs are that like
it really does feel like I said an
outlet and which I think a lot of people
look at that as something they like
write in bed every night they like write
in a journal or they write whatever for
me I think that's expressing myself and
my music
um
yeah now you've said that your dad
actually inspired a lot on this record
how would you say his involvement uh uh
and experience really uh changed kind of
the tone and what you wanted to say with
this album
well my dad really
has been an inspiration to myself and my
music since the beginning but I think in
a sense of really sonically bringing my
music back home and where I'm from and
um a lot of the instruments I use
throughout the album really take me back
home
um there's a lot of mandolin banjo
there's fiddles harmonica
um really any pedal seal any instrument
that you can think of name it and it's
probably on my album but
um that's mellow he's he's in the back
um
but yeah so I mean my my father and also
like where I'm from in Nashville were
huge Inspirations my dad also
um lyrically I think is one of my
songwriting Heroes so I I really I
really studied a lot of his his music
and
um a lot of there's a lot of referencing
I think that I made of my dad's music in
the studio too so I mean I don't even
think there's one specific thing that I
could say
I could point I just every I don't know
my dad just honestly down to like words
that he said to me my entire life like
stand still was an inspiration so there
really were just so many things within
our relationship that really inspired
this album and again this album
a lot of it's about finding yourself and
um going through life as a young adult
in my experience again I think hopefully
this album can reach anyone at any age
and kind of
uh they can they can relate to that and
um
I can I feel like I leave a lot of the
lyrics up to interpretation and and what
you want to make of them
um but for me a lot of that was growing
up and
learning learning to deal with love and
loss and
um also I lost my grandma in the process
of writing this record and I didn't even
really I didn't even really know at the
time I was in the process of writing the
record I was just writing records and
that's when I wrote Loretta's song
um
and now I recently lost my dad's mom as
well August 12th
um and so the album and and Loretta's
song and the song the hardest part and
stand still they just all have such
greater meaning to me now because I
really I just I can imagine both of the
two most important women in my life that
I wrote this record for and my grandma
mamaw who just passed away
um she loved my record and she had all
the songs on her phone oh I love that
yeah so there's a lot of there's a lot
of um my family in this record which I
love so much hey that is so special
um did your dad have a good reaction
when you were playing the music uh on
this album yeah my dad my dad
um my dad loves this album and
um really just
has is so proud that I
am making something I think so true to
myself
um and also really bringing it back to
where I'm from
um my dad my dad loves this album I
don't I don't even think my dad has a
favorite song on this album but yeah he
he he's definitely my biggest
cheerleader